[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's ein superschnelles rezept
wir werden nämlich ein blitz dessert aus
dem backofen machen
wir bekommen ja gleich besuch und haben
gedacht euro wenn man gar kein kuchen da
und nichts süßes für den tisch also
haben wir so kleineberg teilchen gemacht
einmal mit einem lüfter teig den gibt's
zum beispiel aus dem kühlfach genau und
dann machen wir auch eine variante mit
einem selbstgemachten quark öl teig und
die teilchen sind echt super schnell
gemacht ganz schnell im ofen und ich
zeige euch jetzt erstmal die zutaten die
ich außerdem noch benötige ich brauche
50 gramm strecke 200 milliliter wasser
100 gramm flüssige butter 100 gramm
braunem oder weißem zucker 200 gramm
haselnüsse einen teelöffel zimt ich habe
ich vanille extrakt und zum bestreichen
nämlich 1 1 und 1 ist mit puderzucker
das sind jetzt erstmal die zutaten ich
nehme jetzt zuerst die haselnüsse ihr
könnt auch mandeln zum beispiel nehmen
und könnte jetzt fein mahlen
also ich muss sagen haselnuss oder
mandeln reifig tatsächlich am liebsten
hier mit denn sie werden wirklich
wunderbar locker und werden nicht so
matschig und vor allem kann ich
einstellen ob ich sie ganz grob oder
fein haben möchte
erfreulich erstmal die oberen hier weg
und nehme ich die stärke und das wasser
die werden für mich und damit wir der
yucatan eingestrichen dadurch wieder
einfach ein bisschen knuspriger beim
backen und jetzt bricht er dann auch
nicht so schnell denn diese schon
ziemlich trocken und so kann man es
einfach ein bisschen befeuchten
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt natürlich finden
geschmack ein bisschen butter rein
[Musik]
jetzt möchte ich hier die haselnüsse mit
dem braunen zucker und auch weißen
zucker nehmen mit dem zimt und mit etwas
vanille extrakt wer möchte kann zum
beispiel auch ein bisschen
zitronenschale dazugeben das bringt dann
auch noch mal eine frische mit rein
jetzt alles kurz vermischen
jetzt kommen hier die hasel ist damit
rein da müsste einfach das ganze so
aufteilen dass es eben für die acht user
blätter reist und jetzt von der einen
seite auf rollen bis zur mitte und von
der anderen seite jetzt in der mitte
durchschneiden und dann einfach zu
schneiden
ich mach das jetzt ein bisschen versetzt
[Musik]
jetzt höre ich das mit dem puderzucker
und bestreicht die teilchen damit und
während dem backofen sind zeige ich euch
noch eine variante für einen quark öl
teig denn diese variante muss ich
zugeben wird ein bisschen trockener
dafür knackig gehabt und jetzt machen
wir noch mit quark öl teig variante mag
es nämlich auch vorstellen hergestellt
[Musik]
für den quark öl teig verwende ich jetzt
etwas mehl und backpulver vanille
extrakt marca kavak öl zucker und salz
und wer möchte kann den tag noch mal
etwas zitrone an abtrieb aufpeppen
der teig muss ganz kurz nur verrührt
werden und sollte nicht zu lange
geknetet werden damit er schön locker
wird jetzt ein bier ich ihn und rollen
dann auf einer bemehlten arbeitsfläche
aus
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr diesen genauso
weiter verarbeiten also mit bisschen
butter bestreichen dann die haselnuss
mischung drüber aufrollen und
zurechtschneiden und die werden dann
wunderbar locker und flockig
[Musik]
nach dem backen könnt ihr die teile
übrigens auch mit zwischen schnee
bestreuen
superlecker denn ihnen ist es ja auch
jetzt nicht zu süß ihr manchmal den papa
kurz rufen dass da probieren kann so als
würde im schloss wurde ba ba ba ba
kalorien dieser fleisch fleisch zimt und
zucker ist nicht gerade die beste
wertung und da ja auch so verstehen
nicht gesehen gut gucken was wir ja und
zwar morath habe ich einmal eine
variante hier mit yoga knusprig und
einmal mit quark öl teig weich und zu
jetzt sagen so jetzt sagen dass alles
täuscht etwas besonders sein
du sollst das sagen was du in seinem
tiefsten inneren des herzens empfinde
die polizei auch ich probiere es erstmal
ist mit der media receiver knusprig
schulter zu man kann auch sagen super
knusprig oder einfach sagen dass dieses
getrocknet ist es nicht mal spaßig brüse
zimtschnecken nur anders so papa darf
ist weil wieder aufmischen und school ja
ganz wichtig dass wir diesem t auf jeden
fall thw aufgesetzt von ballack muss ich
noch mal sogar das hobby des ohne den
lenker war schnitt besser ich will
beides machen ich würde auch beides
machen ich habe auch andere stars
anderes ist einfach beides machen beides
anbieten und echt zu verlängern ihr
könnt das ganze auch noch auf finden vor
allem die weiche variante zum beispiel
mitgeschnittenen geschnittenen
apfelstücken das schmeckt auch super
lecker
gepäck spielt und ich müsse mir im
zucker mit dem puderzucker ebenso würde
und süße stehen so schnell wie so
schnell richtig cool recht lecker ich
wollte das rezept nach machen wollt
schaut auf sex - blog.de vorbei da steht
alles noch mal ganz genau ich wünsche
euch viel spaß und nachmachen und bis
zum nächsten mal
was macht studiobossen tag fleisch dann
verlasse ich jetzt die küche die chef
übernimmt selbst viel spaß gebracht
über dem stuhl des kommando
[Musik]